- Hello!
I'm so excited to meet you.
- Hi!
- I'm so excited to meet you,
I'm fan girling over here, so
I've, I've been wanting to
like, I don't know, hang out.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah I, I,
I've always wanted to see you live
and the closest I got
was when you performed in
the finale at American Idol
and you were pregnant and
you sang "Piece By Piece"
- Yeah, I was.
- because I felt like
I was there with you.
- Oh that was--
- I sat alone in my kitchen,
yeah crying, ugly crying
in my sweat pants.
- Oh my God.
- And my daughter walked in
and she caught me and she was like,
what are you doing?
Like,
- What's wrong with you?
- she could not put it together
that I would be just crying that hard
- Oh my gosh,
no I'm so emotional.
- at my computer.
- Man, I mean,
you'll get this just being pregnant
like especially at the tail end,
I was about to pop.
- I was so emotional and then like,
- You were beautiful.
- and literally they,
it was supposed to be the end.
They weren't bringing it
back, no one knew that.
So it's supposed to be end of it
and it was my start and
I was so overwhelmed.
It was so bad.
Anyway,
thank you for crying with me.
- Oh no, it was
so beautiful and so honest.
- Aw, thank you.
- That, that's why
I love you so much because you are,
you're so beautiful and so honest.
I could keep going.
This could just be this
the whole time, but--
- Oh my gosh.